on soir madame labit vous êtes
présentatrice du journal télévisé 12
minutes à la rtbf à bruxelles d'abord
faites nous un petit topo de doux en
hélant qu'être là je viens de parler des
frères abdelsam on en recherche un des
deux l'autre a parlé à la télévision
et ces attentats a été inspiré par un
autre quart et passer par bruxelles qui
sera en syrie alors tout ce que voulait
dire est effectivement vrai alors je
vous parle nous avons deux hommes ont
été arrêtés et inculpés pour
participation à un attentat terroriste
qui sont ils on ne sait pas on sait
juste que l'un d'entre eux à 21 ans ils
tous les deux étaient dans une voiture
et ils sont allés vendredi soir à paris
rechercher à des femmes qui les a
appelés en leur disant venez me chercher
je vous paye les sens et les péages
elle affirme qu'ils sont innocents et
qu'ils ne savaient pas qu'il y avait eu
des attentats à paris ils ont néanmoins
été inculpé l'autre chose c'est
qu'effectivement on recherche ce
monsieur abdel claque a disparu dans la
nature et que son frère est tout à fait
innocent il était d'ailleurs très ému
tout à l'heure en parlant à la presse et
à l'heure où je vous parle les gens nous
trois heures il n'y a plus d'autres
perquisitions pour l'instant mais le
maire de nous lever parle d'un réseau et
on peut s'attendre à d'autres
perquisitions pas forcément à molenbeek
né en belgique parce qu'on sent bien que
les enquêteurs ont envie de savoir est
d'aller vite et le président hollande 1
français a dit plus tôt aujourd'hui les
attentats étaient imaginées en syrie
organisé en belgique chez vous et bien
sûr exécuté à paris on le sait donc
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que les forces de
l'ordre dit chez vous sur cette
organisation du complot on dit pas tout
à fait la même chose en tout cas le
président hollande a peut être des
informations que moi je n'ai pas je
n'utiliserai pas en tout cas le mot
organisé organisation parce que je pense
que l' enquête on est qu'à ses débuts et
que c'est peut-être trop fort d'affirmer
cela ce qui est clair c'est qu'il y a
des liens avec la belgique en tout cas
notre
ministre de l'intérieur a dit qu'il
préférait attendre que l'anc est évolué
avant d'utiliser ce mot organisation ce
qui est clair c'est qu'il va y avoir des
développements vu qu' il ya quelques
jours il a déclaré qu'il voulait
s'occuper personnellement de molenbeek
alors un ancien ministre de l'intérieur
au front sera sans doute utilisé
l'expression nettoyer au kärcher ici on
a utilisé un autre vocabulaire ce n'est
pas du tout menacé ça n'a pas forcément
pauvreté l'ensemble du gouvernement ni
même l'opposition mais on sent un peu
cas qu'on veut agir mais pas se
précipiter peut-être aussi parce qu'on
ne va pas je t aime donner une image
négative de la belgique de bruxelles et
d'une commune en particulier qui est
volée qui est ma commune vous pouvez
vous y habitez parlez-moi de molenbeek
c'est une commune donc c'est au coeur de
bruxelles
il faut comprendre c'est pas une
lointaine banlieue et vit dans votre
quartier donc quoi 85% de belges
d'origine maghrébine alors le brosser
ses 19 communes molenbeek et l'une des
plus peuplées où on a 95 mille habitants
c'est la deuxième commune de bruxelles
la plus pauvre alors dans certains
quartiers je dis bien dans certains
quartiers on pourrait parler de ghettos
même si j'aime pas vraiment ce mot parce
qu'il ya effectivement jusqu'à 80 % de
population d'origine maghrébine je dis
bien d'origine parce que la plupart m'a
mentionné en belgique et sont de
nationalité belge
en tout cas une commune qui est pauvre
où le taux de chômage des jeunes peuvent
varier de 28 à 40 %
c'est énorme et c'est vrai que le maire
de la commune il a déclaré sur les
antennes de la télévision
on n'a peut-être pas mesuré l'importance
de cette communauté qui se nomme sentait
un peu rejetés
il ya une un repli identitaire arplay
religion on a laissé faire pendant
peut-être enfin temps et maintenant eh
bien il ya des éléments radicaux qui se
sont fait entendre
vous savez qu'entre 1970 s'est donné
cette population d'origine maghrébine à
cadre plaît mais elle s'est aussi
paupérisés et je vais pas une excuse est
évidemment mais ce n'est pas forcément
facile aujourd'hui d'être d'origine
maghrébine de dire que l'on vient du mot
l'aude et d'essayer de trouver
du travail à beaucoup de joie dans la
rue qui sont désoeuvrés mais c'est aussi
une commune qui est populaire et pour
moi le mot populaire et un mot positif
c'est dans le sens familiale moi si je
suis dehors avec des bacs est des gens
vont venir m'aider on se dit bonjour on
se sème les gens ont vraiment aidé
certaines entraide mais oui il ya des
problèmes en mode et vous l'avez citez
dans votre émission vous savez que les
assassins du commandant massoud un
passeport belge yves beaunesne molenda
et les deux cerveaux des attentats de
madrid qui était de molenbeek médine et
moufles auteur de la tuerie au musée
juif est passé par moments des coulibaly
de l'hyper cacher à paris est venu
chercher des armes ici l'auteur de
l'attentât vitesse est passée par moulin
b donc oui ces derniers mois ces
dernières années on pointe souvent
déboires à vous lever pour quelques
éléments radicaux mais il n'ya pas que
ça maintenant comment reconnaître un un
jeune qui se radicalise c'est pas facile
il ya en tout cas un agent de prévention
qui a été nommé à relever qui est
chargée d' écouter le discours mais gêné
de voir justement comment et à quel
moment ils peuvent basculer c'est un
travail de longue haleine
moi je voudrais être plus de moyens et
c'est pas facile de reconnaître un
radical il n'est pas écrit sur son trou
il va pas à la mosquée avec les autres
il peut très bien se retrouver dans une
maison particulière avec deux trois amis
et c'est compliqué comme travail ne te
ferait belle commune madame labit merci
beaucoup
d'ailleurs on le voyait on l'entendait
le frère s'il si c'est vrai ce qu'il dit
il dit moi j' avais aucune idée que mes
deux autres frère s'était radicalisé et
c est ça peut être plausible on verra la
suite de l' enquête
merci beaucoup pour cet imposant pris à
la prochaine